personnage mythique le premier américain
qui s'est envolé dans l'espace s'est
éteint alan shepard est décédé
avant-hier soir à monterey en californie
à l'âge de 74 ans figure de légende il
restera l'un des douze hommes de la
planète terre à avoir foulé le sol de la
lune commentaires de leur vie vient 5
mai 1961 pour la première fois un
américain s'envole dans l'espace
le voyage ne dure que 15 minutes quinze
minutes qui suffisent à faire d' alan
shepard le héros de toute une nation
il a conduit notre pays et toute
l'humanité
au delà des limites de notre planète
traversant une nouvelle frontière dans
une nouvelle ère de l'exploration
spatiale
le retour sur terre est difficile ancien
pilote de l'us navy
alan shepard souffre d'un grave problème
à l'oreille interne
il est contraint d'abandonner ses rêves
des espaces mais l'ambition est plus
forte que tout en février 71
il commande la mission apollo 14 il est
l'un des douze homme à avoir marché sur
la lune
il est surtout le premier à y avoir fait
du golf john glenn a rendu hommage à son
ami shepard cet homme qui comme lui
avait les tops des héros